you know some people just they just
don't like this belly fat thing they
want it gone so today we're going to
talk about the 10 foods that can help a
person
lose belly fat so let's dive right in
what is belly fat it's visceral fat okay
and here's a book i want to show you
right here
siba the civil collection frank knitter
and this one is on the endocrine system
and we have this little chapter right
here
which talks about cortisol okay you see
this
picture right here
that's belly fat and that's too much
cortisol so
first let's talk about the relationship
between
cortisol and belly fat
cortisol
turns protein
into sugar okay so it causes your liver
to make new sugar
out of
non-carbohydrate things like
fat ketones
protein so if your cortisol is really
high that's a stress hormone you're
going to need quick sugar being created
so your body's going to be making a lot
of sugar so people that have high
cortisol a lot of times are not eating
sugar it's their bodies making sugar out
of other things and that increase in
sugar elevates
insulin okay people can even become a
diabetic if you have too much cortisol
and this is why one of the side effects
of prednisone where someone's taking a
synthetic cortisol
is diabetes so the reason why someone
has belly fat or visceral fat from
cortisol has to do with that hormone
which is making sugar which is then
increasing insulin so really what's
happening is we're getting the spike of
insulin and insulin makes belly fat
because there's a fat storing hormone so
whether your insulin spike is coming
from eating a high carb diet or sugar or
increase in cortisol
or you're eating too frequently as in
having a lot of snacks you can develop
excessive belly fat
now the belly fat usually occurs after
the liver
is
fatty because a lot of the visceral fat
that's around the organs is occurring
because there's a spill over
from your liver so if you're belly fat
like you're looking down right now and
you can't see your feet that means your
liver has a lot of fat in it and now
it's spilling over into other areas
around the body because there's only so
much space in the liver so knowing that
information
the top foods that will help you with
that
have to address
either
lowering insulin lowering cortisol
or helping you with a fatty liver and
some people as i go through the list are
going to be surprised when i talk about
eating certain fats because
you would think you would need to avoid
fat if you want to get rid of a fatty
liver or fat around your midsection but
that's actually not true so let's start
with number one eggs okay what's in eggs
that can help you with your mid-section
weight well number one they have
virtually no carbohydrates okay and that
means we're not going to stimulate
insulin and because it's a good source
of protein in fact the best source of
protein you're not going to get near as
much
waste
as
glucose okay because if you're eating
too much protein especially the wrong
type of protein that can actually turn
into sugar too so eggs are right up
there as the highest quality protein
that you can consume and when a protein
is low carb it triggers the opposing
hormone to insulin and that's called
glucagon and glucagon helps you burn fat
two eggs are loaded with lecithin
so lecithin helps break down fat in your
liver eggs are also loaded with choline
which is also a good fat dissolver for
your liver all right number two
salmon now what's so special about
salmon
salmon is very high in omega-3 fatty
acids it's one of the foods that has the
most omega-3 fatty acids okay and
omega-3 fatty acids do two things it
helps to reduce insulin by making
insulin more sensitive and it also helps
you reduce cortisol and it's virtually
zero carbohydrate all right number three
cob liver or
cod liver oil if you've never consumed
cod liver oil you may or may not like it
i like the taste you have to try it
sometime it comes in can it looks like
one of those sardine cans but it has cod
liver in it and i think it's actually
really good so cod liver is just like
like mostly fat and with some protein
but it's super high in omega-3 fatty
acids which can help you make insulin
more sensitive and also reduce cortisol
but you can also do the cod liver oil
too
but some people don't like the cod liver
oil burps so you can get them in
capsules okay number four
sauerkraut so how can sauerkraut help
you well number one it has the ability
to increase liver function
and there's been some interesting
research that it can help reduce fat on
your liver it's a really good
anti-inflammatory
the fiber can help feed the microbiome
which then turns into a real interesting
type of fat that's very similar to a
ketone and be a source of fuel now
sauerkraut also has probiotics and so
when you consume these great probiotics
through the fermentation process
that alone can help you lose weight
because we have the microbes now working
for us
and sauerkraut out of
all the foods has the most vitamin c
one cup of sauerkraut could contain up
to 700 milligrams of vitamin c i mean
that's just amazing and your adrenals
the gland that makes cortisol needs
vitamin c as a real key nutrient to
support itself as you go through stress
out of all the vitamins that the adrenal
needs uh vitamin c is at the top of the
list all right number five cruciferous
vegetables that would be like kale
broccoli brussels sprouts arugula which
i love there are certain phytonutrients
in cruciferous to help a fatty liver the
minerals specifically potassium and
magnesium
in those vegetables are really good to
help lower stress and help you reduce
cortisol and help you sleep and also
potassium is one of the most important
minerals to help reduce insulin i just
did a video on that and of course
magnesium is a like a physiological
relaxer mineral so it can help you feel
calm and actually sleep and then also
the fiber from cruciferous vegetables
that can help the microbiome because
they live on fiber all right number six
is hamburger now you might be thinking
like why is hamburger on the list i'm
not talking about the bun i'm talking
about a high quality fatty burger that
doesn't have ketchup that doesn't have
fries as a side order hamburger is
basically a combination of fat and red
meat and it's easier to digest sometimes
than red meat that's a little bit leaner
and so that means it has even a lesser
effect on insulin and it's virtually
zero carbohydrate it's nutrient dense it
has a lot of vitamins and minerals and i
consume a lot of hamburger in fact i
feel really good especially my blood
sugars when i consume hamburger but of
course make sure it's uh grass-fed
grass-finished all right number seven
avocado
avocados have something called avocatin
b it's a certain
chemical in avocados
that can help your blood sugars it can
help insulin be more sensitive it can
help reduce insulin resistance and on
top of that it's really good for someone
with a fatty liver avocado is a really
good ketogenic
vegetable because of its fat it has a
lot of fat and it's extremely low carb
and it's a vegetable so you should
combine the avocado with a hamburger
with a little sauerkraut on top all
right number eight broccoli sprouts
now you can use other sprouts but
broccoli sprouts have a lot of the
sulforaphane that's the phytonutrient
that's really good for cancer but it's
also really good for reducing visceral
fat okay there's one study yes it was on
mice but it did show a 20 reduction in
fat from the midsection of a mouse as
well as reduction of liver fat so if you
have some pet mice or gerbils or
hamsters definitely start feeding them
broccoli sprouts broccoli sprouts or
other any sprouts in general are
actually pretty nutrient dense
the most nutrition in a plant occurs in
the sprouting stage not necessarily when
the vegetable
becomes an adult plant all right number
nine is asparagus okay
now asparagus has something in it called
asparagus
and that is a certain chemical a natural
chemical that helps to detoxify ammonia
from your liver
ammonia is a byproduct from protein and
so if the liver is damaged and you're
building up ammonia
definitely consume asparagus but this
phytonutrient also helps with blood
sugars it helps with insulin resistance
it makes insulin more sensitive so
you're going to have less insulin
plus the fiber in the asparagus is
really good for the gut it'll feed the
microbiome which will then help your
blood sugars from another angle not to
mention it's very high in fiber and low
in actual sugars all right number 10
nutritional yeast now
make sure you get the nutritional yeast
that's not fortified with synthetic
vitamins okay because a lot of times
they'll they'll put these synthetic
vitamins that are basically from
petroleum they're very low quality cheap
vitamins but a lot of companies when
they produce the
yeast when they ferment it they throw in
these synthetics and apparently the
yeast eat them and you spike the bee
complex
but you really don't need to do that you
just need to get nutritional yeast
that's unfortified you can either get
them in tablets or you can get them in a
powder and you can put them on your
salad
which is really tasty because it has a
little bit of a parmesan
taste to it you know with your olive oil
and your vinaigrette and here you are
having this nutritional yeast that will
not only give you the b vitamins to help
a fatty liver but it will also give you
a lot of b1 to help reduce cortisol and
stress
so if we combine some of these foods in
our salad we have the magnesium we have
the potassium we have the fiber we have
the phytonutrients we have the
nutritional yeast in there
if we put a little avocado in there
and then the side we have our burger
with sauerkraut one of the perfect meals
to help you lose belly fat all right now
that we talked about the foods to eat
let's now talk about the foods to avoid
which is just as important i put them
right here check it out